THIS IS MY LAST FOR THE YEAR.
SO LET’S GET RIGHT TO IT.
TRUMP’S TRIUMPHS.
THAT IS FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
AS I CLOSE OUT THIS YEAR, I
THOUGHT IT WAS SUPER IMPORTANT
TO REITERATE HOW FORTUNATE WE
WERE TO HAVE HAD A PRESIDENT
LIKE TRUMP FOR FOUR YEARS.
NO SUCH FORGET THE SAVAGERY OF
HIS CRITICS, THE RANK MEDIA
BIAS AND, OF COURSE, THE
CONTROVERSY SURROUNDING THE
2020 ELECTION MAIL-IN BALLOTS.
SET THAT ASIDE FOR A MOMENT.
JUST FOCUS ON WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP AGAINST INCREDIBLE
STRONG HEAD WINDS DID FOR OUR
ECONOMY.
TODAY, MORE THAN SIX WEEKS
AFTER ELECTION DAY, THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" BELIEVE IT OR NOT
PUBLISHED A PIECE CONFIRMING
HOW MUCH TRUMP’S POLICY HELPED
OUR FACTORY WORKERS.
THE FOCUS IN THAT ARTICLE WAS
ON THE CARRIER PLAN IN
INDIANAPOLIS.
NOW IT SEEMS LIKE A LIFETIME
AGO IN FEBRUARY OF 2016,
CARRIER EXECUTIVE MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT THE FATE OF
THE STORIED ENTERPRISE.
>> CLEAR THE BEST WAY TO STAY
COMPETITIVE AND PROTECT THE
BUSINESS FOR LONG TERM IS TO
MOVE PRODUCTION FROM OUR
FACILITIES IN INDIANAPOLIS TO
MONTERREY, MEXICO.
>> Laura: BUT THEN POPULIST,
PRO-AMERICAN WORKER DONALD
TRUMP MADE IT HIS PERSONAL
MISSION AFTER HE WON THE
PRESIDENCY TO ENSURE THAT
CARRIER SAVED THE AMERICAN
JOBS AND KEEP THE FACTORY IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> President Trump: INDIANA
IN THE HOME OF CARRIER, AND
IT’S LEAVING FOR INDIANA.
THAT WON’T HAPPEN IF I’M
PRESIDENT.
>> YOU ARE ONE OF THE PEOPLE
WHOSE JOB WAS SAVED.
>> YES.
>> DO YOU THINK TRUMP FOR
THIS?
>> YES.
>> DID YOU THINK IT WOULD
HAPPEN?
>> NO.
WE HEARD THERE WAS A TWEET.
HE WAS TAKING.
WE HAVE STARTED TO TAKE THE
MEASUREMENT.
THEY ARE GONE.
NO WAY.
HE DID IT.
>> Laura: I WATCH THAT AND
MAKES ME WANT TO CRY.
THE PLANT IS THRIVING.
BUT WITH GLOBALIST BIDEN IN
THE WINGS THEY NOW HAVE A
FOREBODING FEELING ABOUT WHAT
THE FUTURE WILL HOLD.
SOME THINK THEY ARE
STOCKPILING EQUIPMENT TO CLOSE
LATER.
THEY BELIEVE THAT CARRIER
MANAGEMENT TO LUST OFF THE OLD
PLAN TO MOVE THE FACTORIES
1,050 JOBS TO MEXICO.
TRUMP IS THE REASON WE HAVE
THE JOB.
AS LONG AS HE WAS IN OFFICE WE
WERE SAFE.
MR. ROELL SAID.
WE DON’T HAVE THE LEVERAGE
ANYMORE.
WELL, I’M SORRY TO SAY THAT
THE WORKERS THERE, THEIR
INSTINCT IS SPOT ON.
CHINA AND OTHER LOW-WAGE
COUNTRIES INCLUDING MEXICO,
THEY ARE LICKING THEIR CHOPS.
EAGER TO GOBBLE UP THE LAST OF
OUR GREAT AMERICAN FACTORIES.
WITH THEM, GOOD PAYING JOBS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN THE
E.U. TO AGREE IN PRINCIPLE,
CHINA HAS, TO AJUROR
INVESTMENT AGREEMENT.
IT WAS JUST ANNOUNCED.
NOW THEY ARE ACTING
AGGRESSIVELY TARGETING AGAINST
AUSTRALIA WITH
DISPROPORTIONATELY MASSIVE
TARIFFS LEVIED BY BEIJING.
IF JOE BIDEN DIDN’T WANT TO
LOSE TO CHINA HE SHOULDN’T
HAVE SIGNALED HE HAD EVERY
INTENTION TO TRASH THE TRUMP
AGENDA.
E.U. THROWING IN WITH THE
GLOBAL WINNER AND WITH TRUMP
OUT OF THE WAY, THE WINNER IS
CHINA.
IN THIS SCENARIO THE RICH
INTERNATIONAL CONGLOMERATES
WILL GET RICHER.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" WILL GET
RICHER, TOO -- WALL STREET
WILL GET RICHER TO AS THEY
ENGAGE IN GLOBAL ARBITRAGE
WITHOUT A WIT OF CONCERN WHEN
THE ENTIRE INDUSTRIES ARE
DISMANTED AND SHIPPED
OVERSEAS.
ISN’T GLOBALIZATION WONDERFUL?
THEY WILL SAY LOOK AT THE
CHEAP PRODUCTS?
TOYS ARE CHEAP.
BUY A PAIR OF PANTS FOR $4.
WHAT A TRAVESTY.
BIDEN WILL BE A PASSIVE
MANAGER OF OUR DECLINE AS WE
OUTSOURCE NOT JUST JOBS BUT
THE ENTIRE FUTURE.
BUT BACK TO TRUMP’S TRIUMPH.
THIS WEEK’S STUNNING ECONOMIC
NEWS FROM THE FEDERAL RESERVE
THAT WAS COMPLETELY LOST OR
IGNORED BY THE LAME STREAM
PRESS.
THE FED’S PROJECTION FOR THE
U.S. ECONOMY IN CONVENIENT
TIMING EXCEED THE PROJECTION
FROM JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO AS
THE FALL CAMPAIGN SEASON GOT
UNDERWAY.
HMM.
NOW WE FIND ON PAGE TWO OF THE
DOCUMENT THAT THE CHANGE IN
REAL G.D.P. FOR 2020 IS
PROJECTED TO BE NEGATIVE 2.4%.
THAT IS AN IMPROVEMENT FROM
THE PREDICTION OF NEGATIVE
3.7% IN SEPTEMBER.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHAT WILL BE
AN ECONOMIC DISASTER FROM MUCH
OF THE WORLD INCLUDING EUROPE
WILL BE ONLY A MILD RECESSION
FOR AMERICANS UNDER TRUMP.
TRUMP, THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS WHO KEPT THINGS OPEN
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SAVED
THE U.S. ECONOMY.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR 2020
IS EXPECTED TO BE 6.6%.
THAT IS IMPROVED FROM 2.6%
FROM SEPTEMBER.
THIS FIGURE WOULD BE MUCH
WORSE IF WE HAD LISTENED TO
TEAM LOCKDOWN.
THE FED PROJECTS A BOOMING
ECONOMY OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS.
4.2% GROWTH IN 2021.
AND THE 2023 UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
SHOULD BE DOWN THEY SAY TO
3.7%.
IN SHORT, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
EFFECTIVELY SOLVED THE
PROBLEMS CREATED BY THE
PANDEMIC.
HE SAID WE’D DEVELOP A VACCINE
BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
WE DID.
HE SAID WE’D ENSURE THAT THE
CURE WASN’T WORSE THAN THE
DISEASE.
LOOKS LIKE HE DID THAT, TOO.
HE HAS LEFT BIDEN WITH
VACCINES AND AN ECONOMY THAT
IS SET TO BOOM.
IF THAT BOOM DOESN’T HAPPEN,
WE ARE ALL GOING TO KNOW WHO
IS TO BLAME.
IT’S ODD THAT ALL OF THE
NUMBERS, THESE REVISED
PROJECTIONS, THEY GOT SO MUCH
BETTER AFTER THE ELECTION.
ISN’T THAT WEIRD?
NOW, IT MIGHT MIGHT HAVE BEEN NI
FOR US, I THINK, SO THE VOTING
PUBLIC TO HAVE KNOWN THE
INCREDIBLE FACTS AND REVISED
NUMBERS BEFORE THE ELECTION.
YOU BET.
BUT WE KNOW HOW THE MEDIA
OPERATES.
HIGHLIGHT ANY AND ALL
DEVELOPMENTS THAT COULD HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
PRESIDENT.
AND BURY THE GOOD NEWS THAT
REVEALED JUST HOW DIFFICULT
LIFE WOULD BECOME FOR REGULAR
PEOPLE, REGULAR WORKING PEOPLE
ONCE AGAIN UNDER BIDEN.
YEAH, WE WILL BE BUILDING BACK
BETTER ALL RIGHT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT WILL BE
HAPPENING IN CHINA.
NOT HERE.
CERTAINLY NOT IN PLACES LIKE
INDIANAPOLIS.
WHERE I’M AFRAID THAT CARRIER
PLANT’S DAYS ARE NUMBERED.
TO ALL OF YOU GEORGIANS, YOU
ARE GETTING READY TO VOTE.
MAYBE YOU ALREADY HAVE IN THE
SENATE RUNOFF RACES.
YOU ALL SHOULD BE ASKING
YOURSELF WHICH SENATORS WILL
BE MORE LIKELY TO SUPPORT
POLICIES THAT MAKE IT HARDER
TO SHIP JOBS, MANUFACTURING
JOBS OVERSEAS?
WHICH SENATORS WILL MAKE IT
EASIER TO DO SO?
ALSO, WHICH SENATORS WILL WORK
TO PRESERVE ALL OTHER GOOD
PAYING JOBS INCLUDING THOSE
THAT RELATE TO THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY?
WELL, I THINK YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER.
TONIGHT, I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FOR WHAT YOU DID FOR THE
FORGOTTEN MAN AND WOMAN ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND FOR AMERICAN
INDUSTRY.
ALSO FOR THE FAMILIES THAT
DON’T WANT HANDOUTS.
THEY WANT A GOVERNMENT THAT
WORKS FOR THEM.
THEY WANT TO DIGNITY OF DECENT
WAGES FOR A FULL DAY’S WORK.
THE LAST FOUR YEARS ARE A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE DOING FOR
THE PEOPLE.
YOU MAY BE BRASH AT TIMES AND
THE LIBERALS DON’T LIKE THAT,
MR. PRESIDENT, BUT YOU’VE GOT
THINGS DONE.
YOU PUT AMERICA FIRST.
AND THAT IS WHAT IS TRULY
IMPORTANT.
MERRY CHRISTMAS TO ALL OF YOU.
MERRY CHRISTMAS TO THE ENTIRE
TRUMP FAMILY FOR WHAT THEY
SACRIFICED FOR THE LAST FOUR